hi there I'm Seth Juarez and I've gotten
two boys and you're a principal
researcher and Lukas Java chief
environmental scientist at Microsoft
with me today to discuss an exciting
initiative that applies AI to
sustainability issues called AI for
Earth welcome my friends thank you
welcome
awesome let's start first with what is
AI for Earth yeah well so the world's
got some pretty pressing problems I
think that's no secret in my opinion one
of the biggest ones is the increasing
impact of human activities on Earth's
natural systems and that really begs the
question of how we're going to use all
of this incredible technology and
artificial intelligence that we're
creating to help societies thrive in an
increasingly resource constrained world
Microsoft's been deeply committed to
environmental sustainability for a long
time and that's why last week we
announced the public availability of
this new program AI for Earth which is
really dedicated to deploying the full
scale of Microsoft's AI services and
technologies and research investments to
organizations on the front lines of
environmental sustainability to
nonprofits academics and government
entities to help them solve
environmental problems faster that's all
so that we have a chief environmental
scientist on staff at Microsoft first of
all what are the key areas for AI firth
so AI for Earth as a program focuses on
climate agriculture water and
biodiversity conservation the way the
program is actually set up is in with
three pillars we're looking to provide
access to organizations to all of
Microsoft's AI technologies we're also
looking to provide education so that
those organizations actually can take
advantage of the services that we're
making available and then finally we're
also offering an opportunity to work
directly with us as Microsoft employees
to deliver some showcase projects and so
the demo that we're going to be showing
today is actually an example with some
partners where we bring all of that
together both access education and
collaboration awesome so AI Firth is
using AI to help with environmental
mental challenges that happy alright so
let's look at this demo that you that
you're talking about can we do that yeah
we definitely can awesome so this demo
is all about you taking a deep learning
approach to a pretty common task which
is trying to build land cover maps so
land cover maps are just classifying
Earth's surface into things like forests
fields water impervious services like
roads and houses so trying to go from
those high-resolution images that people
are so accustomed to looking at today
and actually turning those into labelled
data points we've been working with two
partners two really important partners
for this project once a small
organization on the East Coast called
the Chesapeake Conservancy and another
is a large software provider that is a
major player in the GIS or geographic
information systems software world
called ESRI of course yeah and what
we've been doing there is Chesapeake
Conservancy with their partners spent a
lot of time and a lot of effort putting
together a data set that's really kind
of the first of its kind of high
resolution one meter resolution data set
of the Chesapeake watershed on the East
Coast and the reason that that's so
important is because for the first time
it provides us as AI researchers the
opportunity to have an incredible
training data set for a deep learning
approach right because the AI
applications that we're building are so
data hungry and in environmental
applications were often times data poor
so this gives us an opportunity to drive
a deep learning approach to create
hopefully a first of its kind a high
resolution land cover map for all of the
United States so before we get to the
demo why would a land cover map be
important like I'm thinking AI for Earth
we're going to program robots to pick up
trash but that's clearly not what we're
talking about here why would this why
does this particular application help
when it comes to environment yeah so for
instance land cover mapping in
particular it is the first thing that
you need to know before you can start
making appropriate environmental policy
and managing our natural resources right
so you need to be able to look down and
understand what is where how much is
there and how
is it changing can you imagine trying to
ask a financial services manager to
manage a investment portfolio without
letting them understand what's in their
portfolio what trades have been made
I've never anything like that
yeah because I used to live in Las Vegas
and Lake Mead has gone down tons and if
you don't have a land cover map that
shows you the differential upside you're
not going to know what's actually
happening that's right all right let's
see what you got my friend so let's
let's go here so what I wanted to show
you first was a set things in context
for you a little bit so what you're
looking at here this is ESRI software
called arcgis pro that were running this
application and and what you're looking
at here is across the united states a
one meter resolution open government
data set so this is produced by the US
government through a program called the
national agricultural imaging service or
program
sorry we're getting ourselves back up to
speed here perfect yeah there we go all
right so tell us what we're looking at
here so people didn't get to see it
right so what people are looking at here
is a map of imagery across the United
States been collected and made available
for free by the US government okay and
then over here on the East Coast you can
see where there's a bunch of different
colors of greens and blues that's a map
that this organization Chesapeake
Conservancy with a bunch of their
partners in the region put together to
convert that imagery into actually label
data so as we zoom in here you can see
that they've taken this imagery here and
converted it into roads and houses
fields and forests so that the computer
can actually understand what that
imagery represented these vector vector
data on top of an existing map that's
right that's it now now I'm starting to
understand it like I said I had this
dumb idea of robots picking up trash
yeah but here we're actually looking at
some vector data over wheel but I'm
noticing that the little green part is
actually really small right because I
looked at the United States that's right
and I saw like hey there's a big United
States and then this this is the only
data we have right and what and what's
actually available for all of the United
States right now is that 30 meter
resolution and it's 5 years old
that's not helpful that's not helpful so
yeah if you're trying to manage lands in
the in the in real time it's almost
impossible at the moment to deal with
with resolution that encompasses you
know roads and houses and many other
things all within one pixel and is over
five years old so where's that like I
understand like the mapping I'm where's
the machine learning part of it that we
want to talk about so what we did was
what we use this data set its training
data for an algorithm that would then be
able to be used across the United States
right so while this map is hugely useful
in the Chesapeake watershed over on the
East Coast it's not all that useful
everywhere else in the US so how do we
create a single algorithm that's capable
of course working where it was where it
was born and bred right but also capable
of classifying land cover in Oakland
County Michigan for instance and I'll
show you an example of this how it all
works let's do it everybody and if I
pause with questions humor me a little
bit of yep please no please do so so I
just wanted to show you the data set
here but what I'm going to show next is
a is a web application that we built
so after training our model we were able
to just output that model file and host
it in in Azure and in Microsoft cloud
that is something that could be queried
with any imagery from anywhere and so
this is that same location in the
Chesapeake watershed and you can see
that just with a click of a button when
I click here this rectangle will become
highlighted the service will segment
that image out send it off to our model
file and in real time send back a result
that has the land cover classification
so you can see in just a few seconds in
that same region where it was trained we
were able to classify land cover almost
instantaneously and as you can see quite
accurately we can also go up here and
you can look at how we're doing with
houses for instance and you'll see that
there's two boxes that I'm showing here
one is the actual final guess that the
algorithms making I think that's a road
a house a forest or a field then the one
above it is actually a mixture of
probabilities from the model and that's
really helpful from a research
perspective because I know we have a bit
of a research audience and extend
which I verily watching today because
that really lets us understand how the
algorithm is thinking and that's what we
might need to do to start to improve it
what additional training data sets we
need to go back to the picture here
because this is this is pretty
impressive you're saying that you've
taken this data that there you go you
can see it now you've taken the actual
data you trained it so that now the
machine can automatically create the
cover
that's for it essentially that's and the
one of the top is showing the
distribution of where the sort of like
the likelihood of this being that's like
light green I guess it's like grass it's
already filled the EPI agrees for nd so
the bottom is what it predicts the top
is here's how I feel generally about
about that that's exactly right because
you know unless you have a perfect model
which statistically speaking you kind of
don't want to anyway for generality
there's a nonzero probability of it
being any of these different service
right and so the model has to decide
which is which ultimately and so when
you look at it this way you get to see
how well ultimately in the bottom it
thinks that's forest and that steel but
you can see there's a little bit of
hesitancy one way or the other and that
really is helpful for us to be able to
understand how to make this stuff not a
voice are you kind of is sitting here
but now I want to ask you what how how
is this done what's the AI techniques so
this project is actually similar to the
previous segments that you're talking
about the segmentation project of course
yeah the difference I guess one big
difference is that instead of looking at
lots of images that are segmented lots
of smaller images we're looking at one
huge image this is ten million
kilometers squared and as Lucas
mentioned we are trying to classify it
at the resolution of one square meter so
it's one humongous image that we're
trying to classify and what we've been
using here are these convolutional net
neural networks which consists of
multiple layers of processing each layer
will convolve the image with a bunch of
filters that automatically learn from
the data and then the output is going to
be processed again and we have dozens
and dozens of these filters of these
layers and then at the at the end we
have a classification of each pixel into
its corresponding land-cover label we
did
have to change the the tools that we
started with and we started with a
without coming to toolkit which worked
fairly well but in order to adapt it to
this application which hasn't been
really used with these type of tools
before we had to innovate a little bit
in terms of making them also more
sensitive to shape rather than color
because as you can imagine you have
rivers that look one way or the other
way they could look very dark very
greenish orange or they could even look
white if the if if they are empty which
happens so to be able to to be robust
all of these things we have to change
the representation little bit to be more
relevant more more relying on shape than
color texture we're also looking at all
these things in multiple scales and and
then basically what happens is you take
all the data from Chesapeake Bay you fit
into learning algorithm it runs for a
few days and out comes a model file that
book is mentioned which you can then use
to classify things anywhere now does it
generalize pre well as I'm imagining
like I'm putting it over like the middle
of Nevada and it's like it is it going
to tell me about that yeah so I'll let
the boy should speak to the technical
aspects of that we can show you one area
where it does generalize and then maybe
as no-budget gives an example if that
was the next lesson yet does it do
because I just tested it on like what we
painted on it men's right that's a good
indication about okay and so would
imagine in the areas where which looks
similar Chesapeake Bay's things very
well right and that's probably what
we're going to show now right yep so
what I'm showing here is a land cover
map in Oakland County Michigan this time
okay okay so we've moved from the east
coast of United States to the Mac in the
middle Emma right and the reason that
we've moved here is because this is a
county that have also put together one
meter resolution land cover map for
their jurisdiction right but this is a
hugely resource of intensive process for
these organizations and so they did this
seven years ago and that's what you're
looking at here the seven so we're
looking at the cut and if we get that
back on the screen we're getting the
seven year old data back here that's our
seven years old
that's okay cool and this image
is a year old okay of the exact same
place so you can see that a lot has
changed sure a particular this
intersection has gone from a
t-intersection to around about right and
of course this is going on with housing
developments Road developments and many
other things and so if you're not
staying current with your if your
algorithm isn't currently updating you
too much more current information you
can quickly fall further behind so I'll
just show will zoom into that same
location I'm sorry so now we're going to
the location in Michigan that has really
good data but five years ago yeah and
which our algorithm has never seen
before of course and I'm looking at this
and it looks a little different yep
so we'll click here and so it's using
the same model that we use generated
from the Chesapeake Bay that's right to
predict what's going on here that's
right in a plate like we said in a place
that it's never seen before and where
they have existing land cover maps book
which are now out date and you can see
with the click of a button we were able
to update that old land cover map almost
instantaneously right that's amazing so
that that's a strong statement towards
transferability Geographic
transferability we're still but you know
I'm showing you one place where it works
beautifully sure there are many places
still where it doesn't and the voice you
can talk a little bit about how we're
moving forward to tackle that Nevada is
a great example where our algorithm
currently thinks forests are areas
desert SAR forests which is the you know
is about as wrong as you can be but this
is amazing though because this makes it
you can do for example you can sample
areas that are representative small
areas that a representative of many of
the areas in United States and then use
those models to generalize over the
entire landscape is that right that's
true and in addition that's why I
mentioned that we are trying to make the
most more reliance on shape other than
colors so they generalize better so for
example they work in Bellevue where I
live and don't see the water on over my
house they actually are classifying now
well in in CL area but beyond that if
you want to move to other sort of labels
like swamps and
whatever other people are interested in
types of fields are your cultural
developments and so on then we could
benefit from new types of label data but
we're trying to build these algorithms
to require as little label data as
possible so if a user downloads a new
class or wants to correct our map
somewhere they can maybe work on a
hundred meters and that dollar algorithm
will then use that to generalize over
acres in that area so the way we are
seeing this kind of going forward is
that since we're not always going to be
interested only in half a dozen classes
that we're looking at right now but even
more and and we are going to be have to
adapt to different types of landscape
then we are hoping and we expecting
actually that every users and and other
people interesting all this would work
on downloading the data into the same
Depot which you can visualize the tools
like this and then everybody's work
would then get amplified by these
algorithms and we'll generalize over
over all the areas so someone out there
is really concerned about the
environment and they want to want to
help out hey donate an hour of your time
labeling some some map that maybe we've
never seen we suggest here's ten that
you can work on they can set that upload
that we retrain the neural network it
gets better and then it can they believe
in yourselves oh that's exactly right
that's the real power I think of machine
learning approaches in this space is
that when people are doing the hard work
right they know that the work they're
doing right now makes their life easier
into the future and I think that's just
so important because people have become
so accustomed to recreating the wheel
over and over and over again every year
going through the same steps to create
the same map just to see how things have
changed in this instance you you do a
lot of the hard work up front as nobody
said you let that algorithm train for
days and days and days and now it's
incremental after that right now and
then it's just a little bit the change
can have transformative effects of the
algorithms accuracy across large
geographic areas and I think the cool
thing is that you can in theory and you
tell me if I'm wrong you can use old
data with old maps to still Train good
models you can yes you can so these
I mentioned the multiscale approaches
but the data the old data with a 30
meter squared could be used to bootstrap
the learning as well I seen so but our
goal is to make all of that sort of
Trance kind of in the background so that
is basically the tool that you're using
which looks like a map you're labeling
things to downloading things you're
making predictions and so on
the algorithm is in the background
adapting everything you're doing and
becoming better over time so that's
really it's about humans using these
things and communicating amongst
themselves and making decisions that
just over time gets easier and easier
for them as a result of the previous
work so just to finish up at the time
went by really fast is real interesting
where is AI firms going next as a
program this is the first big year we
were just launched last week we're super
excited to be here at faculty summit
because we're actively looking for
academic collaborations in this space
this project in particular will be
looking to start to deploy our algorithm
at a national scale to be able to figure
out just how accurate are we already and
what research breakthroughs do we need
to make over the next 12 months to be
able to really nailed it awesome well
thanks so much for being with us no boy
Shawn and Lucas thank you for your
demoing conversation day thanks for your
work and thanks for making the earth a
better place